kevin gausman native of centennial
colorado
born about 15 minutes away from coors
field
betz who was one for three with a walk
in game one
there's a hard one hopper to short
crawford gloves it on a in between hop
to his left
throws to first for the out one hop top
spin
109 mile an hour ground ball to vanna
crawford who says
that's the way i like him a two out walk
to turner here in the first day
now a swing and a high pop-up third base
side there's nobody playing third
crawford hustles over from short right
to the foul line behind third
and makes the catch and caleb ferguson
will take it for
probably the first inning maybe the
first inning plus on a bullpen game
the longest he's gone so far this year
isn't ending in a third he's done that
three times so two down and evan
longoria to deflate
the 1-2 longoria swings a little
comebacker with
ferguson goes to first at a one two
three inning for caleb
ferguson he's one out nobody on in the
second inning no score
goes up and gets that one cranks it in
the air straight away and gone
jack peterson climbing the ladder and
then sending the ball
straight center field for his fifth
and the dodgers on the board first for
the home run
mr peterson got it ball out over the
plate hit it out over the
defense so jock had a base hit in the
first game of this doubleheader
came into this game with a seven game
hitting straight
they've gone six up and six down they
have not had a base runner in this game
one-two bart strikes out swinging on it
brandon crawford coming up
swings and misses it a slider the second
strikeout
second out of the inning now joey record
coming
check swing no on appeal rule to swing
that's strike three
victor gonzalez strikes out the side
with the hitting conditions oh so tough
he took advantage
i just took care of business in the
first game they were four for nine
in spots like this with runners in
scoring position well let's see what
will smith can do
drilled to left center field back deep
into the gap will smith brings home jack
peterson
back to back two out doubles and it's
two nothing
as will smith delivers a two out double
the dodgers have a two to nothing lead
and the dodgers were the two out rally
two ounce nobody on base back to back
doubles and increase their lead that's
going to get the giants bullpen moving
around
bruce stark gradual third pitcher of the
game for the dodgers
good to owe longoria comebacker and
grinderall
kicks it out of the air on one hop
throws to first
12 up 12 down two-nothing dodgers lead
giants don't have a base runner yet
it's about time branded belt stands in
belt
has got the first hit for the giants and
it comes on a 1-2 pitch
first hit first base runner for the
giants here in game two
bart struck out in his only at bat in
this game he was the dh in game one and
struck out three straight times now with
two out of ground ball
right to gavin lux and he will throw
across the diamond
bart is done so are the giants we go to
the six
dodgers two justin turner who got hit by
a pitch
is at second max muncie who walked
is at first pollock pinch hitting for
jack peterson
ground ball to second not hit hard
backhanded by solano to crawford for one
crawford the first
double play now that is a flashy double
play
and it's a spot where a uh a powerful
swing
could turn this whole game around swung
on and missed strike three foul tipped
it into the glove of will smith tried it
with a
big strikeout there's two out so two
down
and here is longoria swinging the ground
ball to the third over to his left
muncie's got it the throw to first in
time
and the inning is over so the giants get
a threat
but the hits are just not there they've
had only five hits in the doubleheader
it's kenley janssen 15th time he's come
in
came into this series he was perfect
with seven for seven he had a save up at
game one did not cash in
so he's now seven for eight sixteen
strikeouts and two twelve and two thirds
with four walks
four pitch guy fastball curveball slider
cutter
lots and lots of cutters but he will
throw the other pitches
so here's belt belt bunts it and he's
going to reach
so there's your base runner you can go
up there try and swing for a long ball
but you're the lead off hitter you're
down by two bart
still his first week as a big leaguer
two down giants down to their final out
outside ball four and it gives brandon
crawford a chance with two on and two
out
swung on and missed strike three and the
dodgers shut out the giants
twice today seven to nothing in the
first game two to nothing in the second